Hey,
what's going on is bill bird.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
[inaudible]
uh,
checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
I am just checking in to see how your week's going.
Now see,
there's a lot of people out there in the podcasting world.
They will do one podcast.
They'll fucking talk to you.
Yeah.
They'll tell some fucking stories.
They'll do some ad reads for old zip
recruiter and they'll say goodbye.
Yeah.
And you don't hear for them.
Those motherfuckers
for the rest of the Goddamn week.
See those those podcasts.
Yeah.
They don't care about you the way I had to.
You see,
when we give yourself to Jesus.
Yeah.
And you understand that we're all brothers and sisters.
I don't look at y'all.
I don't look at Yo.
Yeah.
Not just a bunch of listeners.
I look at you like my brothers and sisters.
Praise Jesus.
Praise Jesus and gave me fucking money.
And when it rains that and the waters come up,
I ain't letting you in my fucking arena.
Um,
I still love that.
He didn't fucking let anybody in.
Joel Olsteen fucking dudes a gangster,
man.
Fuck you.
You ain't get my blue carpet all wet.
All right.
Jesus wants you to get wet.
He wants you to float out into the Gulf of New Mexico.
My eyes adored you.
I can't get that fucking song on in my head.
No,
I never laid a hand down.
Would you mind?
Don't you fucking some man fucking something in a fucking,
something so close.
So close.
Sad yet.
So far.
Oh,
I carried you fucking books to school.
That song is so fucking sad.
Yeah,
it's a sad song.
You know what I lived at?
I used to do,
you know something?
I was on a,
I did an episode,
you know,
I got these big shows coming up.
F is for family.
Third season is coming up.
So I'm starting the old,
um,
promotion tour.
Like right now.
Right now I have 20 minutes between radio phones.
So I figured,
Hey,
you know what I mean?
I'm a guy.
I'm a guy who does a podcast.
Right?
It'd be nice to get 20 minutes of this podcast out of the way.
That's what I'm doing right now.
As you're sitting there going,
wow,
this guy bill checked in on me.
He really cares about me.
I'm actually right now trying to get this out of the way.
Okay?
If you want,
full disclosure,
all you people out there,
all you kids out there in the Internet,
you know,
sniff and fucking glue and fucking trying to make water stand up after you throw
him.
Yeah,
I talked about that on Conan.
I just don't understand why everybody finds that so fucking incredible.
You know,
when you really think of the technology out there,
the fact that you can take your own fucking unmanned helicopter and fly it over
some,
over somebody fucking yard and watch some topless chick,
10 in her fucking tits,
right?
You can do while watching that in you've in your fucking room.
Okay?
Beaten your fucking millennial Dick.
You know,
all of his teeth you would take,
it's something somebody flips a fucking water ball up in the air.
If it stands up upright.
Everybody runs out of the room.
Like they just saw a fucking,
which is incredible to me.
You know?
That's what's fascinating.
That's just fascinating about entertainment.
You're never,
you have no idea what's going to be a fucking hit and what is it?
Right?
Just fuck just sitting there.
You're right.
This shit.
You shoot the shit.
You put it out there.
You have no fucking idea.
That's why when something is a hit,
Hollywood's like,
oh my God,
they like vampires.
Fucking make 900 of those until they get sick of it.
Then they move onto the next thing.
Like I,
I'm kind of hoping the Superhero Shit is,
has it finally died down.
I was driving down the street the other day,
but I do by duo.
Boop.
And I saw a billboard by Bata,
no pope.
And it said the world has enough superheroes and it just said venom.
And I was like,
oh my God.
Finally.
Yeah,
they're going to make a movie about one of the bad guys.
Right.
And I can guarantee you if this movie venom is a Fuckin hit,
next thing you know there's going to be Alexa.
Is it Luther?
Is it Lugar?
Is it Luder Lex,
the bald guy?
Like make you know
whose whole fucking thing?
Yeah.
Is that like he just can't,
he can't stand fucking superman and his full head of hair.
Do you know I was talking to somebody just,
you know what it is.
It's not even a full head of hair.
It said he has the audacity to have that little curly cue right down the front.
Just mocking,
you know?
I bet Lex had a nice sense of humor at one point before he got all bitter.
You know,
I bet lexicon baby tell a story.
I bet Lex had some fucking attributes that made him special,
you know?
But Superman got that jet black hair done.
They,
yeah,
it's so black.
He has blue highlights.
Yeah.
You know that is uniform.
Just sets it off.
Which brings out his eyes.
What color are his eyes?
That's when you know you're,
you're like two windows superheros when you know,
like what color their eyes are.
First Time I opened a comic book and I saw his steel blue eyes,
I was just like,
oh my God,
who is this?
I felt like I just want to just in the ocean of ant man's eyes,
what do you guys think about stem cell research?
I don't understand why this country is okay with one con one company,
you know,
taking over the food supply,
poisoning it,
and then selling the company to another company and everybody just walks away.
Like what they did didn't just happen.
Like there's not fucking eight year olds walking around with full fucking
Baird's because of all the fucking hormones and shit that they've put in the
goddamn food.
I don't understand why this country is okay with that,
but stem cell research is like,
oh,
that's the work of the devil.
And then you hear all these fucking stories of people leaving the country.
They go out,
you know,
and they get the stem cell treatment.
Okay.
And they come back to this country.
It's like,
I thought this guy was a mouth breathing moron.
I mean he just explained the theory of relativity to me.
What the fuck happened?
Oh,
he got stem cell research on his mouth.
They shot it right into the gaping hole that he used to have.
When he would stare at you mouth agape,
when you would flip a bottle over and it would land on upright,
they shot it right into,
it was like a mist was a stem cell mist and all of a sudden his eyes lit up in
his mouth closed and now he's a fucking smart guy.
Yeah,
no,
I've heard about guitar players like their hands from years of fucking doing the
tap on Solos trying to keep up with Eddie van Halen.
You know,
they fucking get that thing and they come back and they have the hands of a 12
year old,
but they,
they keep the experience of being on the road to devastating combination.
You would think something,
you know,
you'd never,
it's one of the few times it seems like you're going to have your cake and eat
it.
I mean,
any sort of movie,
if I'm right in that movie script,
that guy has the hands of a 16 year old,
but he loses all of this fucking experience,
uh,
being on the road and all of a sudden he's got to go play a fucking arena and
everybody wants to legend and he's coming out there with these young hands,
but he can't remember his songs.
Man.
He can't remember resolves
[inaudible]
okay,
I got my fucking hands fixed,
but I can't remember how this song goes.
I fucking don't remember this shit even though I'm the guy that fucking wrote
it.
You know that's a Netflix series right there.
Then you just see what it's like.
The Hulk Meets Eddie van Halen and that'd be fucking the end of every episode.
He walks away with this guitar,
you know,
hitchhiking.
Cause he got booed off the stage again because he couldn't remember how it went.
And like every fucking episode,
he remembers a little more of his catalog,
but he has to
practice so much that he's fucking up his hands again and he's losing money
because nobody showing up.
And now he's not going to have the money to get the stem cell research again.
So of course the woman that fucking spun his blood in the center fuge becomes
his love interest.
Is Anybody writing this down?
This has to happen.
All right?
You have my permission to go into Netflix and you pitch this series.
Okay?
You want to,
you want to see a fucking streaming services,
um,
industry person's eyes fucking light up.
You just walked in and go,
I've got an idea for a show.
It's like the incredible hulk makes Eddie van Halen and I guarantee you,
you won't even have to get through the pitch and there's going to be a fucking,
they're going to slide that check across the table as they play the,
the,
what's that fucking song?
That quick little son they play.
It's almost like when you watch law and order
[inaudible] they're going to do that except the Netflix on.
It's sort of just a note,
right,
isn't it?
They just hit one note.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
yeah.
Yes.
Shell.
It's,
it's like,
it's like captain America
meets CC Deville.
Just hear me out.
Well,
my only question would be how does he get his hair underneath that mask?
I mean that's,
that's what bumps for me does.
Does he slick it down?
Do we see some hair coming out of one of the eye holes?
I think that could be funny.
Do you guys think that could be,
I think that could be funny
though.
I never laid a hand on you ma.
What's my fucking time do I have before the next phone or I got to do bill?
Were you always funny as a kid tells?
What do you find funny today?
How do you come up with your material?
Do you have writers?
The pull from your real life?
I just did an interview with these guys.
These guys were great,
but in the end they go,
hey,
bill Cosby just got sentenced to 10 to 15 years.
What do you think about that?
Yeah,
well,
I mean,
nothing funny.
Are we going to end on this?
Um,
anyways.
Anyways.
I mean that's,
that's right up there with fucking,
uh,
what's his face?
The tight end from the Patriots.
Yeah,
just viewing somebody one way and all of a sudden you just look at him the other
way and you're like,
Holy Shit.
And it just fucking affects the whole,
the whole way you look at their work.
Bill,
can you,
can you separate the comedy from the drugging and the raping when we return?
We've got some more.
MMM.
Bill are,
you're familiar with the Hindenburg crashed and we have audio new audio just
surfaced we find on a 78 speed LP from back then of people on the Hindenburg
screaming as they burned to death.
Uh,
have you heard it yet?
In what are your thoughts?
This,
tell the folks what you're going to be joking about.
MMM.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
let me a,
I get seven more minutes before I got to hit pause
and move on to this next one.
So anyways,
this stem cell research,
you know,
I've got this fucked up shoulder and I just been,
fixing it old school.
I'm thinking maybe when I go to Eastern Europe,
you know,
when I have a day off on my tour I'm going to fucking stop in to some local
place and like Transylvania or something had my blood spun,
you know,
good evening by one of these fucking guys.
Right.
Is it true that white people in Eastern Europe have fled heads like Frankenstein
too?
They have like bolts coming on to the side.
Um,
I dunno.
They were behind the fucking iron curtain the whole time I was growing up.
So anyways,
I was talking to somebody about this shit
and [inaudible]
a buddy all of a sudden like this is all the stuff that people are whispering
about right now.
Hey Buddy of mine was in Australia and he got his knees done.
I,
I saw him the other day.
He was jumping higher than a fucking pogo stick.
Right?
And all this shit's getting in my head I'm going like wow.
Stems.
This is fucking incredible.
Does it have to do like a baby has to fucking die or something for them to be
able to do it.
Is that what it is?
Does the rest of the world not care about dead babies?
They just look at him like a fucking rusted out car,
you know,
like a parts car cause you're,
you're,
you know,
you just
take it a little baby liver out of it and somehow you put,
I mean you don't bill,
it would probably help if you fucking read up on it.
They actually,
this guy was trying to tell me that through stem cell research they've actually
cured male pattern baldness,
but there's so much money in fucking people like myself throwing Rogaine on
their head,
I don't do that shit.
I did at one time and I leave,
felt my heart speeding up.
Now I don't know if that was just the panic of me dealing with the fact that I
was going bald or if it's actually a side effect.
So allegedly my heart rate went up.
I have,
you know,
if it was,
I can't remember what the fuck was.
This was back in the two thousands
in the year,
2000 pounds in the year 2000
mmm.
And P be fucking hilarious.
Do you understand how funny it would be if they actually had a cure for fucking
baldness,
but they're just making so much money on the snake oil that they don't let it
come out.
I was joking last night with some buddies of mine going,
do you realize that that that would be like,
like Rogaine and all of those guys are kind of like big,
big oil companies.
And then the cure for baldness would be like electric cars or solar,
you know,
and I gotta be honest with you,
I don't think that's the cure for like fucking
yeah,
the environment.
Cause you know,
goddamn well all the raw materials and when you throw out your old solar panels
or the,
your fucking Tesla ends up in the fucking ocean,
that giant fucking battery,
God knows what it's gonna do.
The environment.
But I'll tell you right now that will,
that would be the end to isis.
That would be the end of so many of these fucking terrorists groups.
How are they funded?
They're funded with oil money,
you know,
so if both pollute the environment,
but only one if I'm finances,
the fucking cops were fighting.
Why don't we just switch over?
You know,
if every stadium in the NFL could go from natural grass,
most of them I should say over the astroturf and then convert to sort of astro
turf with old rubber tires in there.
If you could watch the NFL,
that billion dollar fucking industry industry changed three times in your
fucking lifetime.
Why is it that we can't switch over to,
we should be having solar power with full heads of fucking hair,
you know,
and then we'd be,
then we,
I think,
I think I just solved the entire Middle East problem in about 90 seconds.
You see that?
Do you see what happens
when,
when you're sitting by yourself and there's nobody to question your thoughts or
debate you on any of your points?
Do you see how quickly
you are able to fucking solve problems?
And what do you mean this?
I just got a text message saying he didn't fucking call anybody.
Yeah.
You didn't,
you missed one of your folders.
I called
the six 45
and
the fucking
7:00 AM fucking cunts.
I gotta put this on speaker here.
Whoa.
Hold on a second.
Hang on a second.
People,
according to my email,
I don't have another phone call until 7:30 AM
period.
You gotta go with a period when,
when you do something like that,
you know,
cause it's polite,
but it's Kurt and then there'll be paranoid.
Like,
is he mad at me?
What is his tone?
And then they back off and then they go,
oh,
I'm sorry,
my mistake.
Even if it was my mistake,
they actually take responsibility.
And that's how,
as a person that stands on a stage and performs,
that's how your ego slowly goes out of control,
you know?
And you see examples of it.
It would be like seeing another standup comedian talking about what other
standup comedians should or shouldn't be talking about on stage.
It'd be like,
if that happened.
Um,
yeah,
as far as I know.
The next one I'm calling our backs in O'brien,
BA and O'Brien in east Longmeadow,
Massachusetts.
And this is gonna hype.
My show in Springfield on October 4th at the mass mutual.
I can't wait to do that Gig,
man.
You got to understand like how many gigs I did in western Massachusetts that did
not go well.
I've told this story.
I went out to exit too.
I got off in Lee,
Massachusetts.
I stood on stage in a restaurant.
I had a dinner roll thrown at me like fucking Nolan Ryan fucking through it.
Thank God it missed me.
Jesus Christ sounded like a fucking gunshot when it hit the back of the behind
the wall behind me.
I Dunno if it was a stale role or what,
but I'll tell you right now,
I'm still shaking.
You know.
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
there's a text message.
See,
I told you the period always works.
I shit.
I fucked up.
Got My time zones mixed.
Mixed up.
I'm sorry.
See how that works.
Let me,
I'm gonna read this back to you and said,
I called the six 45 and the 7:00 AM period according to my email.
I don't have another phone call until 7:30 AM period.
And You keep it like that.
No question marks.
No.
Is that cool or is it me?
You just fact period.
Fact period.
Send
skip the seven 31 I'll reschedule it.
Oh,
look at this.
I'm going to get to knock out my whole podcast,
Ma,
don't ya
though?
I didn't fuck up my radio tour.
Somebody was waiting for role.
Freckles.
The fucking collar man.
Talk about his fucking shit jokes there is going to be telling at the mass
mutual fucking center in Springfield,
Massachusetts.
They got the fucking NBA hall of fame.
You know I love about that place.
You get to go in there and take fucking you.
In the end.
They got some hoops.
He can shoot a couple of fucking hoops.
Take a three pointer.
You know I've been to all of them.
They don't have a batting cage at the baseball hall of fame,
nor should they,
because that's,
that's the purest one.
That is the hardest one to get into.
You know what I mean?
You have a better chance of banging a fucking supermodel than you do of getting
into the fuck.
You understand that.
Then getting into the fucking major league baseball hall of fame
because you know,
you go to fucking New York,
you go to La,
you walk down the street,
you'll see one of those supermodels walking down the street looking like a
fucking giraffe and high heels.
Maybe you say something,
maybe you could maybe get,
throw him a line.
Yeah.
Maybe you go reverse psychology.
You look at their designer bag and just as like,
is that from,
is that uh,
I wish I knew line of a cheap line of purses,
something,
something that makes them question themselves.
You know,
not that I've had this experience before,
but I would think that if that is what your job is
okay.
Every fucking day you just looking in the mirror and knowing you're another day
older.
Yeah.
And that,
oh Jesus,
what am I talking about?
That's the business that I'm in.
Do you know what I mean?
These people that come out here and they base it on their looks or get shit
because of their looks,
you know,
everybody,
like they always look at them,
you know,
and that they love them and then eventually they,
they,
they fucking,
they don't like them anymore cause they're good looking and their beauty reminds
them of the horror that they see every time they brush their own teeth.
Yeah.
You walk into the bathroom.
Actually had somebody install a dimmer.
Okay.
Yeah,
the light on like 30%.
You just come walking in,
right.
And just out of memory,
you know,
you're looking down because you just don't want to catch,
you don't want to catch what you see in the Mary.
He just looked down.
You grab your toothbrush,
you put the toothpaste on it at some point though.
Okay.
You have to look up and you have to face you.
It's sometimes she don't like what you see.
MMM.
That's a tough fucking game.
You know?
It's funny about really good looking people.
Like they're the only people who get called out for aging.
Have you either either that or people you went to high school with?
Well,
back to my high school reunion.
Jesus Christ.
Bill Bird looks like he's fucking in pappy on.
MMM.
That'd be almost his friends for Jose.
A butterfly
that bill,
excuse me.
Mom and Mozilla
[inaudible]
um,
done.
Frigo
is a butterfly in the,
in the refrigerator.
Why is the butterfly the refrigerator?
This is when you learn French.
This is a kind of shit you learn how to say like shit.
You would never say if he went to France,
excuse a mom and my Zillow Eylea
uh,
[inaudible] now Frigo a [inaudible] wait,
wait.
Okay.
Basically should I fucking throw the thing out?
Cause it's obviously dead
kiss.
Say uhmm sorry.
Like I'm not going to fuck torture you with my goddamn French.
I already did that to the,
to the wonderful people of France who had the fucking decency to say we're not
going to accept that poisoned food from your country and unless you fucking
label it
and then the wonderful people of this country like garage,
no Fuckin word rolling afraid.
And we'll turn the floor.
Yes.
They talk like the devil and a heavy metal record.
That's how I picture those people.
We're going on a complete roll or whatever.
Put it in your mouth and eat it.
Well,
we will stop making food.
Um,
I know this is fucking weird.
What do you mind for me?
It's like fucking seven in the morning and you're supposed to be up right now.
Yeah.
This is literally like a vampire fucking getting up at noon to fucking watch the
prices.
Right?
Like I should not be,
yeah.
Seven 50
Bam by watching the prices might come up.
People.
That's fucking funny.
It's funny to me.
In the morning,
high or higher watching the games.
No
one fucking drew Carey retired from the prices.
Right.
And they hired a vampire to host it.
You know,
they'd have to start doing the tapings at night.
Good.
Even the
bell come to the prices,
right?
Oh my God.
I'm going to fucking pitch that to fucking Hulu.
All right.
This is like a game show meets Bram Stoker's,
whatever the fucking,
I never watched any of those stupid fucking movies.
The last vampire movie I watched was Brad Pitt.
It fucking,
um,
no,
that's not true.
I watched the one where the little girl was the vampire,
her and her and her dad moved into the complex.
Yeah,
that was a cool one.
That isn't true.
I just thought I just basically caught myself in a lie,
you know?
Do you know,
it's been like a month since I've flown a helicopter and I just keep seeing
these fucking magnum pis Bao,
Bao,
[inaudible] my,
with that fucking song goes,
that's one of the songs you can't hum except at the beginning band 80 knee and
it just goes off.
Goes up the fucking real.
We'll bill.
Maybe if you watched the show a little more.
Um,
you know,
it's fucking weird about that show.
Like,
oh boy.
Well,
let me get to the point.
Every time I see that fucking,
that beautiful MD 500
when he's flying that fucking helicopter,
I'm just like,
I'm like,
I'm really like,
I'm watching that fucking show.
And I liked that they went old school with the helicopter,
but I feel like they should've given him a new Ferrari
because that's not one of the classic Ferrari's like that is not worth
a lot of money,
you know?
As far as Ferrari's go,
like you could,
you could pick up one of those fucking four RVs.
Let me,
let me know.
Let's say it's fucking,
look at the price of one of those fucking things right now.
What do you say?
They're freckles.
All right.
We're looking up Tom Sell Ferrari.
They,
we're going to see how much you'd fucking costs magnum,
not condoms.
Magnum P I do do,
do,
do better.
[inaudible] like I came from Margot's magnum Pi,
Ferrari.
I was the three Oh eight gts.
All right,
let's look that up.
F E R r a r I
what did I just say?
Three.
Oh,
a g GTB and GTS.
Okay,
let's see.
Uh,
the front meter.
Oh,
you fucking Wikipedia.
Can't
Goddamn motherfucker.
Why does,
why is it my,
all my fucking defaults go to those assholes.
You know what?
Probably cause you went to it too many times.
Ah,
this douche again.
Wikipedia,
the bald Khan has another question for you.
Tell them I'm not here to like,
hey her bell could see again.
What,
how old is Gavin Macleod?
Ah,
fucking 85 alright.
Ferrari 308 gts for sale.
Now I imagine the price went up cause magnum p coming back bowed out out I own,
I own [inaudible] all right.
Three Oh eight gts for sale.
I remember Barry Katz,
I trashed him on his own podcast.
He owned a half the stand ups in the fucking world money and he went out and
bought one of these things.
Yeah.
54,000.
It's still a lot of money.
79,000 get the fuck Outta here.
Oh,
that one joy.
[inaudible] Huh?
I don't know why I said her name.
I just want,
I just want to say her name.
She was one of the coolest fucking people I've met in this business by the way.
Don't sleep on fucking joy Behar.
I did an episode with of crashing with her and she was fucking hilarious.
All right.
Uh,
64 five.
What about the ones from the 80s 83 is 79,000 1980 70,000 Jesus,
you know something.
When people buy Ferrari's in the supercars,
everyone thinks it's a giant fucking waste of money,
but you know they really retain their value.
There's no way that fucking car costs that,
Ma,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say it didn't cost that amount of money when
you first bought it.
It actually appreciated in value
after what these bankers did,
did this fucking country in 2008 this people in houses that are never going to
appreciate in value as far as what?
They still own it on
people.
I'm telling you right now,
if you want to turn around your financial fucking situation,
you sell your house,
you buy a Ferrari fucking JTS and you live in that mother fucker,
eventually that car's going to be worth more money than you owe on for your
house.
What are,
well,
you sold the fucking thing,
but you still owe more than what it was worth.
You know what I'm saying?
There's a balance there that needs to be dealt with.
You don't drive it anywhere.
You just fucking do alternate side alone,
weak fucking parking.
And you just sit in it too.
One day that fucking car is worth more than what you owe on your house,
plus a Turkey Sandwich.
Then you sell it.
Then you walk down the street,
you get yourself a Turkey sandwich and you like,
you know what?
That's delicious.
And now I have nothing.
MMM.
What's that country where bankers get put to death if they do shit like these
fucking constant in this country.
You know,
is it Singapore?
Is it somewhere in Malaysia,
Thailand,
Laos,
Vietnam,
India,
China,
Mongolia,
Japan,
Guam,
um,
DG.
We heard he mooned in Fiji.
We had a hot,
it was so amazing.
You look through the floor,
you could see the fucking ocean.
It's one of those things like if I was a woman and my husband took me to one of
those fucking huts that sits over the ocean,
like I,
I wouldn't be able to sleep comfortably
because I feel like if your husband's ever gonna fucking kill you,
it's either going to be 20 years into your marriage or on the honeymoon.
So you got to get past that first hiccup and just knowing that this dude could
kill you and then just drop you right through the fucking floor.
You know?
Any other thing,
ladies,
if I can give you any advice,
like you want to be in a hotel so he,
if he drops through the floor,
you landed somebody else's room and at least he's going to get caught.
You know,
don't go to that fucking hut that's on stilts above the Goddamn Ocean.
Don't take a cruise,
don't go scuba diving.
These are all fucking stories you hear.
I Dunno if they're true.
It's just people you know,
say them and then I repeat them without ever doing any research.
There was that woman,
she went on a fucking honeymoon and somehow she got eaten by a shark or fucking
like the guy shut off the oxygen tank.
It was on the fucking honeymoon.
This is why they should have a fucking class in high school teaching people how
to get out of a relationship.
Do you understand?
This person was in a fucking relationship with somebody that they did not want
to fucking be with and all they had to do is just sit down and say,
listen,
we have to talk.
I'm not happy.
I love you,
but I don't love you in a way that makes me want to marry you.
I'm sorry.
And that's all you have to say.
How long did that take to say that she's going to cry?
Be Shocked,
possibly throw something at you,
call you in the face,
call the police and said that you attacked her and then you go to fucking jail.
Right.
Fucking with you.
But I'm just saying it's literally a fucking fifth.
It's a 15 second statement.
I know it's awkward.
You don't want to fucking do it,
but just memorize it.
Just sit down and say it so you're not standing there at a fucking wedding
going,
what the fuck am I doing?
And just avoiding confrontation and standing there going with this ring Iowa,
do you flop sweat?
Fucking jackass.
Agree to take this woman who was fucking ecstatic because she doesn't know what
you're feeling and you're sitting there,
your head's going,
don't say it.
Don't say it both Sadie,
you go,
ah,
I do do,
do,
do.
And then you're like,
now how the fuck do I get out of this?
Now I'm going to get divorced one day maybe.
And that's a combination that the fucking divorce laws is so fucking brutal
and all these strong women are out there getting fucking ridiculous amounts of
money for child support.
He saw the whole fucking thing.
So do you realize rather than just simply breaking up with the person,
this fucking guy goes,
I know
we're going to get certified to scuba dive.
We're going to go underneath the ocean.
I'm going to shut up for fucking tank and went to work.
This whole fucking story of having never committed any sort of major crime.
I think I'm going to sit across from the cops and be able to hold it together
and get away with fucking,
I'm going to break the fifth fucking commandment and for the rest of my fucking
life,
I'm never going to enjoy one day knowing
that I took another life.
Do you know one time that I know I'm off the rails here?
I,
you know,
one time I fucking,
there was this rapper from Africa and he was one of those boys,
soldiers over there that fucking gets commandeered at like nine and kills more
people than fucking Rambo by the time he's 11.
Um,
he was talking when his album came out,
he was talking about,
uh,
all these rappers in America that would brag about killing somebody and he was
fucking,
he said one of the coldest things,
but like so true.
Well,
he was just like basically saying they were full of Shit.
He said,
when you kill somebody,
you don't brag about it.
It haunts you.
And I was like,
oh my God,
I got to listen to this fucking guy's album.
You know?
I mean,
how do you not fucking listen to that guy?
if you're listening to this shit,
I know what you're saying right now,
but what is the guy's name?
I don't remember,
but I don't think there's a lot of fucking boy soldiers that turned MCS out
there,
you know?
All right.
Have I talked enough?
I have to do a little bit of advertising here.
People,
I don't have the advertising yet because I'm so I had the fucking game,
you know?
I feel that I did the upon,
I just did the podcasting equivalent of doing the dishes before you go to bed.
I'm tell you about if you suffer from fucking depression,
not clinical,
but just fucking low tickets going to work out for me,
man.
If that's what your fucking brain says to you and you want to start turning it
around,
I'll tell you something.
Nothing lifts your spirits.
Yeah,
like fucking common downstairs in the morning and all the dishes are done or
walking across your fucking apartment and maybe you're in a fucking studio.
Okay.
And the sinks right next to your futon.
Hey,
I've been there.
Yeah.
Knowing that Faucet keeps fucking tripping and you can't get it to shut up.
Shut up seats,
put a towel in there and you just lay there thinking that you solved the problem
and then eventually the towel gets too wet and rather than hearing the sound of
the water hitting that fucking stainless steel at then becomes the fucking towel
and you just hear.
Yup.
And then you start thinking,
maybe I could get certified,
just go scuba diving with my landlord
rather than call an a pla.
All right.
Um,
yeah.
That and making,
making the bed,
make the bed before you go to work.
Come home.
Do you know something?
I don't know what it is.
You get into a bed that that's made,
it's,
it's more fucking comfortable.
The sheets are all fucked up and everything.
He just,
it's just,
it's awful.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you grab a newspaper off the newspaper stand and nobody's read it,
it just,
uh,
it's just CRISPR.
The words jump out at you.
But if you pick one up at the bus station,
you know,
pull it off with some bumps fucking face,
which sleeping right.
It just doesn't seem the same.
And you know what,
that's one to grow on.
All right.
Um,
I'm gonna shut this off and then I'll fucking splice everything together and
you'll,
you'll never know the difference.
All right,
this is weird.
You know,
I guess it's just pretend like I already have the advertising.
All right.
People,
why don't we do a couple of advertising reads here.
Hey,
what's going on?
All right.
It's Bill Barr.
I'm back.
I always have to say,
hey,
what's going on when I'm starting,
I'm trying to get the fucking copy here for the,
uh,
the goddamn reads.
And of course it's not working out.
Why would it work out?
Why would anything I totally fucked up with my goddamn computer.
The thing was filling up.
It told me it was going to be filled up.
I fucking ignored it.
Now.
It's now,
it's completely fucking full.
And I keep trying to put them onto these little fucking lightening sticks.
Whatever the fuck he call them east sticking the Saudi computer.
First one worked fine.
Got All the pictures and video on it.
Second One AG.
Go Fuck yourself bill.
Now I got to play a game.
Now I only have it on one of these fucking sticks.
They are called lightening sticks in my world.
All right,
Amigo.
Uh,
no.
That's as ami go.
Yeah.
Like you know,
it's funny.
Back in the day you could read Lord and Taylor,
Jordan Marsh.
Now everybody's gotta be so goddamn cool.
Oh,
am I a g o Oh my,
go.
Oh,
me,
go.
Oh me,
go me go.
Our Revolutionary Toilet seat replacement for your folk in age.
Are you anal about cleanliness in the bathroom?
Have you really ever thought about wiping with toilet paper?
Like really thought about it.
Please click for a demonstration in details.
Yeah,
I'm going to skip that.
A wash
washing you and all the right places.
Oh,
this is the,
all that,
the thing here.
So it's like a bad day.
Is that what we're talking about?
Yeah.
All right.
Let me see.
Okay.
They got this smiling guy.
Meet Amigo,
Amigo.
All my go.
All right,
let's listen to this.
Oh,
see
you see this.
This is the past and frankly that's toilet paper.
Let me introduce you to the future.
This is Amigo,
a new high tech toilets and it changes everything.
It's going to spray water up your ass.
First thing's first installation.
I'm no handyman,
but it's fast and these just to,
he's no handy man and there's a woman fucking doing it.
Yeah,
there she is.
Plug it in here.
She's ready to go.
I can't tell if that's sexist or empowering.
I mean he didn't know how to do what she did,
but she was on her knees in the bathroom.
The first thing you'll notice is that the seat.
Oh,
for fuck sakes.
How fucking long does it have to be?
All right.
Evidently it sprays water up your ass
and that's the way of the future.
All right.
It just,
the water temperature,
the position in case it's fucking,
it's treating your taint like it wants equal rights.
What water?
Water temperature position,
pressure with movement with,
yeah.
I guess there are different size assholes out there.
Features,
heated seat.
I'll fuck goodness sake.
Are you serious?
You see,
I'm trying to learn how to not not curse in front of my daughter for goodness
sakes.
J C F and
G.
D F C.
Um.
Alrighty.
Heated seat.
A nightlight soft closing air dry,
remote controlled.
Deodorizer is there not enough global warming that we gotta turn this thing?
I mean,
how about what's,
what is the carbon footprint in this fucking thing?
Say Goodbye to toilet paper.
Save trees.
You're saving water.
Fuck you.
Save saving water.
Maybe I'm save water and electricity by having a heated seat and water spring up
your ass as opposed to a cold seat with toilet paper.
You,
US alone uses 36 million rolls of toilet paper in one day.
Clean and safe.
Automatic self cleaning on demand.
Silver Ini sterilize.
Install yourself in just 20 minutes.
Get a hundred dollars off your,
your order when you go to all my army,
go doc.
All my go.
Amigo,
my amigo.com/bird that's o m I g.
O.
Go to Amigo,
my amigo.com my Amigo,
my amigo.com/ [inaudible] to get $100 off the future.
Seems Weird at first.
Let it be weird.
All right.
Maybe I'm behind the Times somehow that's more environmentally friendly.
Oh,
look,
look who it is.
It's not us.
It's him.
A,
here's a problem.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35.
Hey,
that's a sensitive subject with me.
Thing is when you start to notice hair loss,
it's too late.
Um,
all right,
well,
I guess I don't need to pay attention for the rest of this.
It's easier to keep the hair you have then to replace the hair.
You've lost.
Oh,
this is fucking genius.
We already got the ball guys dumping shit on their head.
Let's get people who have full heads of hair to get paranoid.
I love this.
Uh,
is that hairlines
whoa
at starting to recede.
Start to move backward.
Any bald spots yet?
How will you feel a year from now if it's business as usual up there?
I thought you just said,
if you're already losing your hair,
it's too late.
Some of these kids,
the way they write their copy,
our boy,
I'll tell you why the guys turned to weird solutions or do nothing.
Well,
what the fee we get shitting on me.
Yeah.
This,
this,
all of this copy shitting all over me.
Uh,
when they can,
they can turn to medicine and science.
I wanted to age naturally.
Gotcha.
Uh,
what hymns does is connect with real doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss well known generic equivalents to name brand prescription
prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counter supplements,
prescriptions solutions backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to four hymns.com h I m s.com.
What about for hers?
Women Have Alopecia sometimes answer a few quick questions.
Doctors were review and can,
can prescribe you a product has shipped directly to your door order.
Now my listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 right now while supplies
last.
See websites for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Well,
you could also see the doctor as opposed to this shit.
Will you say doctors look at it.
How the fuck do I know?
You know,
go.
Go to for
hymns.com/bird that's f o r a h I m s.com/birth for him,
hymns.com/burr.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Getting down and dirty on the last one.
My bookie,
everybody.
That's right.
Who's playing tonight?
Thursday night football.
I don't know who's playing to be honest with you.
I have no idea.
I knew.
Wait,
I do know Monday night football is Denver and Kansas City.
Yeah,
Thursday night football.
Steelers.
Tampa Bay was Monday.
I don't even know.
All I know is I'm watching.
All right.
You know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people by asking me for advice,
ask me what team to bet on tooth is.
I have fucking know who's gonna win.
But you know what?
If you think you're going to,
if he fucking take,
you know,
you gotta check out my bookie.
Remember who you're betting on is just as important as who you're betting with.
Think about it.
Make sense after a while.
That's why I always tell people to bet with my bookie.
Trust me guys,
they're your best bet for this season.
They've been in business for years,
have great reviews online,
and their mobile side is easy to use.
My bookie,
you,
when they pay,
I mean that fucking simple.
They have in game,
live betting the most rewarding perks in the business and for you fantasy guys
out there,
oh my God,
he's on my fairness.
The team.
Fuck it.
Have one wide receiver.
It'd be you.
You can even bet over the,
over under on how many fantasy points of player will score each game.
My bookie is slammed with new betters and wants to give everyone the best
service possible.
If you're willing to deposit after 7:00 PM eastern time,
they'll give you an additional $25 free play on deposits over $100 joy now and
my bookie will match your deposit dollar for dollar use Promo Code Berbee you
are ours.
Activate the offer.
Visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie,
And don't forget to use Promo Code Bur when creating your account to claim up to
$1,000 in free play.
And now if you're willing to hold out until after 7:00 PM,
you can get an extra $25 free play by using Promo Code B,
U R R two five.
It's up to you guys.
But I'd wait to after dinner and take that extra money.
Hey,
you can do it all you want.
You play,
you win,
you get paid.
I fucking love it.
MMM.
How the fuck is adding electricity to a toilet seat?
More environment and,
and fucking a water fountain up your ass more environmentally.
I mean that,
that right there.
That right there is,
is the reason why I don't invent shit because on paper,
man,
that don't make no fucking sense.
All right,
you guys enjoy the music.
There's going to be another half hour of a,
um,
a greatest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
I'm going to be at the La Forum tomorrow night wearing a Larry Bird Jersey.
No,
I won't.
I wouldn't do that to you.
I thought about it,
but I'm not going to do that.
Why not?
Why not make it an enjoyable experience?
I'm gonna be at the La Forum tomorrow night.
Get your tickets.
You only got one more fucking day.
Come down there and see.
Oh,
freckles.
All freckles now.
Big Old fucking place.
And I'm in Denver.
Well Dude,
I called it the pride of Newark,
New Jersey.
Paul Versey,
owner of an absolutely beautiful,
uh,
Toyota,
Lexus,
Teddy.
Say it Lexus by Toyota.
All right,
have a great weekend.
You can go on
Pat
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
like a boss
that's like,
okay.
I really cry.
And I just think it's nice that after all these years,
the amies finally stepped up and gave everybody else in award.
Um,
Jason is,
my wife was watching that thing last night.
What a fucking
shit show.
A lot.
Hey,
dapper stranger.
Need a lift.
A drifter in the van with the kids.
Sure.
I don't know,
man.
I gotta tell you something.
There's no way that it's worse for someone who is into watching award shows.
I don't awards show to make them watch sports.
There is no way that that's a worse experience than someone who watches sports.
Having to sit there and watch your fucking,
the Emmy's,
you know,
I didn't have to sit there.
I kinda had it had to because uh,
you know,
I didn't see my wife and a couple of days and she was like,
I want to hang out with you.
And then we had to sit there and just watch these fucking things.
It just,
Ugh,
the actress,
it just so God damn dramatic.
Yeah.
Amy Goes to
Sarah
[inaudible].
This is the first Emmy Win and sixth nomination for Sarah Paulson.
I had one of those mouth wedding drops and now I can't feel my face.
So this is a problem.
No,
wait,
it was because you thought I could that I even dared
because you believed in me.
I dared to try.
I almost fucking threw up whoever the hell said that because you believed in me.
It's like you're a fucking actor.
It's a killer script.
You what?
You're going to turn it down.
That fucking Oj miniseries was,
was unbelievable.
Turn up the pressure pressure.
You want to turn up the pressure?
I don't believe in me,
but because you did.
I dared,
I dared to try.
Oh,
it was
worst things I've ever heard,
you know,
other than when you call them the cable company,
if you want to get these kids,
when you get into that,
talking to a robot lady is one notch lower than that.
I'm not shitting on the actor.
You know what I mean?
They get got it because they like that.
That's why they give the great performances and because I'm a cunt,
that's why I do stand up.
You know what I mean?
So everybody finds a little fucking hole is supposed to crawl into,
oh my God,
there's always easier.
These are important stories and they need to be told
stories that provoke conversation,
necessary conversation.
And it also creates privilege.
When you take women,
people of Color,
trans people,
Queer people,
and you put them at the center of this story,
these subjects,
instead of the objects,
you change the world.
Oh,
did we found out?
I found out.
Just take your shiny thing and leave.
Just give us the keys.
Ugh.
Oh God.
Because you believed in me.
I dare to try.
Um,
I dared to try.
Okay.
The next time my wife compliments me,
I'm going to say that to her
because she believed in me.
I dared to try.
Um,
these are stories that need to be told.
We're storytellers.
It with us,
without us giving people a voice.
You know what else?
Who's great?
You know,
as the Emmys,
I think the Emmy's got scared by all this shit.
They Oscar's gone,
you know,
and what was funny is many people of color,
that one,
one of the funniest shots all night long was when,
you know,
if you looked,
if they just would like do a shot behind Jimmy Kimmel and you saw the front row,
it looked like a great mix of everybody.
But when they did the,
the shot,
when they'd come back from commercial and you saw the whole crowd,
it was like from the thousandth row up to the third row,
it was all white.
It was like,
it looked like a foreign,
a concert for the back row.
All the way like the third rail.
But if they did it the way they shot it,
they front end loaded like the 15 black people that were there.
They just had them all right in front the juice box.
You would like a juice box.
There you go.
Take the whole thing.
Some Asian people and all that,
but all the way to the back.
I was joking with Nia like you,
if you live in New York City,
every once in a while you go into one of those Bodegos Etsy that deal with drugs
that just going out of business,
a little corner stores called Bodega's.
Say it with me,
both Degas and it looks like it's fucking stocked with food and you grab that
one can of food and you look and it's like behind that can,
that's just completely empty.
So I did get some laughs while watching it.
Jesus Christ,
the weight of every fucking thing that they say.
It's just unbelieve.
It's just like that inside the actor's studio when that fucking guy just sits
there like I hope you realize the presence of greatness that we are at.
You know,
just like Jesus Christ.
If you fucking get pretending to be a fireman,
relax.
We've arrived at a difficult moment.
Of course.
Um,
it was so brave.
It was such a brave performance.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's fucking people update at the end of building skyscrapers and shit.
All those guys who go up and they change.
You ever see those things might Mike palms literally sweat watching these
people?
They climb all the way up those towers to change the fucking light.
The little light bulb at the top of the tower at the top of the fucking
building.
So,
so plain.
See it at night.
And they got that part where they unhooked the safety thing.
Free climbing is more dangerous of course.
But Osha rules do allow for it.
Jesus Christ it putting on 20 pounds and wearing a wig is brave.
What the fuck is that?
Huh?
You can't die acting,
can you?
Well,
I guess you can't
that there's ways to die as an actor,
right?
The fake gun on set turns out it's got,
you know,
you put it up to your head.
Does that they believe fucking bring a helicopter.
People have died on set.
So no disrespect to them.
29 minutes,
a Yammer inbuilt Jesus fucking Christ.
You know,
some days the podcast is hard.
Other days it's easy.
But I just wanted to say to everybody who lists,
yeah,
because you dare to download.
I dare to try.
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built burn.
It's the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
September 27th,
2010 and uh,
and it is still Monday for all you fucking assholes giving me shit.
And I haven't,
you haven't posted a podcast.
What the fuck's going on?
It's still Monday.
It's still Monday morning.
We're out where I live.
It's not my fault.
I live.
I live at the end of the street.
You know,
I live at the end of the fucking street when it comes to the world.
You realize that shit other than Hawaii,
you know,
and maybe a Amelia Earhart's fucking great,
great grandson of grants on at this point,
right?
And be grandson she crashed,
made it to an island.
Fucks him
Goddamn Aborigine,
right?
Bang to two ends up having a fucking baby.
Some fucking group of people that we haven't figured out that they lived there
yet so we could exploit them,
destroy their goddamn culture,
and she put up a fucking best buy.
You know,
maybe,
maybe those are the only people who don't bitch at me.
It is the Monday morning podcast.
It's nine 43 Monday fucking morning.
Okay,
so there is the Monday morning podcast.
All right.
The epic fail guy who sent me the email.
You want to see an epic fail?
Why don't you look up when
you're shaving next time buddy.
All right,
I'm going to fucking mood.
I am in a mood today because my computer sucks.
Server not found.
What does that even mean?
What the fuck?
How am I offline?
Uh,
Jesus.
Now you guys are going to see what kind of skills I really fucking have
considering I'm not even online right now.
They just took away my,
my little security blanket.
Um,
hey,
somebody sent me a,
a,
an email talking about irony.
Um,
you know,
the Segway,
that little two wheeled thing where you lean forward and it goes forward and
then you lean back and then it stops.
Just something like that.
Evidently it's,
it's,
you know,
it's a,
one of those devices they made because I think that they felt like people
weren't fat enough and if there's any way,
if we could just eliminate all walking.
Uh,
anyways,
just the segway owner died,
uh,
after falling off a river cliff riding a segway.
Okay.
I know it's,
it's not a nice thing to do to laugh at someone who dies.
I know that they have family saw.
Um,
um,
you know,
well what the fuck
and just the whole name of its segue.
You know,
the segue brought him from this life into the afterlife.
That was the segue.
Jesus Christ,
I want,
what was he thinking on that fall?
Hi.
[inaudible].
Oh,
and you know,
he was wearing those fucking shoes with the tassels.
You know,
those ones that rich people,
where are those fucking loafers?
You know,
they always wear the loafers without the socks and they got their khaki shorts.
And some sorta yachting Polo shirt.
I bet he was dressed like that.
He's probably on his cell phone.
Maybe he was texting while he had another one up against his chubby rich cheek
from all those fucking Hammes he used to eat at that long dining room table.
Yeah,
we going to take out my segue,
go further to spin around the fucking river that we bought.
And you know what'd be fucking hilarious is if you only went over the cliff,
I bet he had a death grip.
You ever heard of what a death grip is?
Well,
I'm going to tell you,
even without the Internet sometimes,
uh,
when,
when you're,
you're,
when you're in a situation where you're going to die and I think it involves
falling,
your body has what's known as a death grip and it's,
you just hang on so fucking tight.
Like I saw this one time,
it was basically,
there was,
there was two guys flying in a plane.
Two guys flying into a plane,
walk into a bar.
The bartender says,
Hey,
you,
you can't fucking park that in here.
What's the deal?
Two guys are flying this fucking plane,
right?
And,
uh,
the rear aft,
I believe they say was a,
was making some noise and they thought it might be a little bit of jar.
So the copilot goes,
I'm going to go back,
I'm going to get up and I'm going to secure the door in the after section of the
airplane.
So the other guy says,
yeah,
I'm gonna sit up here with my fucking seatbelt on.
You go over there and,
uh,
learn about air pressure.
So this fucking dude goes back and he,
and in his efforts to secure the door,
aft of the airplane,
the Af section of the airplane,
we need all of you to take yours feet,
please.
We haven't gotten to a full stop at the jetway yet.
Shut up.
You can't.
Um,
he goes back there and
I don't know,
he went to try to shut it and the fucking door pops open.
This is one of these small Cessna planes.
You know where you open the door,
like the stairs are on the inside of the door and you plop it down and then he
come down.
If some horror puts a lei around your neck,
one of those planes,
then you go surfing and get fucking hit by a Tki or whatever,
one of those planes.
So the door pops open and this guy somehow as he goes to fall out,
he's falling out backwards.
Or maybe he grabbed the railing or whatever.
All I know is this fucking dude
went out the plane.
So the pilots up front going,
holy fuck,
my friend just died.
So now he's got to land the plane,
which isn't a problem.
But the problem is is that the door was ajar.
The door after the AF section of the airplane is now a jar and he's wondering is
it going to drag?
Long story short,
he fucking lands the plane and when he gets out of the plane or walks to the
back of the plane,
he sees the copilot laying like head at the bottom of the stairs,
feet like still in the plane and his hands gripping the fucking skinny little
banisters.
So he tries to get this guy to let go and the guy is in like this catatonic
state and the the fucking announcer,
the host of the show was saying it took the fucking fire department 20 minutes
to pry this guys fingers off of the Goddamn Bannister things because he had
what's known as a death grip.
I mean do you realize just mentally where you go in that moment where your brain
overrides everything other than keeping your heart beating and your respiratory
system going,
the only thing your brain is saying is don't fucking let go grab on.
And that shit,
it's just,
it's not even saying,
hang on,
I think it's just white noise.
It says,
hang on,
you have that thought and then it's going
nonstop until
you gradually come out of it and you look in intake upside down.
Firefighters face.
That's stupid mustache and the smell of Chile cause he cooks in a firehouse
telling you it's okay to let go now.
So with that long fucking story,
I bet this fat son of a bitch had a death grip on his segway,
went right to the bottom of the river.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
You know what kills me is that thing was completely fucking useless.
Completely useless.
I don't understand what,
what purpose it served
and that guy made,
he became a billionaire.
The problem was is that they were 10 grand.
Cause you know goddamn well if those fucking things were 500 bucks,
everyone would have one like a fucking iPod.
We would just be going down the street
looking like the beginning of one of those star wars movies.
You know where they have all the uh,
what does that,
what does that computer technology that they always use that ruins every fucking
movie.
That's what it looked like.
It looked like that computer technology that I don't know the name of and I
can't even tell you what it is cause my fucking internet isn't working.
So anyways,
the body of 62 year old
James Helston Hazeldon and a segway personnel transporter
were found in the river wharf.
I don't know what the fuck you said.
And he was pronounced dead at the same,
I'm sure he was with his fucking legs sticking up out of that river mud.
He might,
I bet he hit terminal velocity when in there.
Like a fucking meaty or there's probably some conspiracy there is trying to say.
It was actually a flying saucer and they just covering it up and they actually
killed this guy.
Um,
police said a witness had reported seeing a man fall Sunday over a 30 foot drop
into the river near Boston spa 140 miles north of London.
The incident is not,
the bleed is not believed to be suspicious.
Police said is it believed to be ridiculous.
I would've loved to been there.
Listen to those cops making those fucking jokes.
Just the awkward silence and then somebody fucking kills it with a joke.
It had to be something,
uh,
that I can't think of right now.
You guys want to write a joke for that?
I'll read them next week.
That's your,
that's your homework assignment.
What did the fucking London police say?
The first guy who made the joke about the segway guy who went fucking 200
something miles an hour into the bottom of a river bed with his own fucking
invention.
Has that ever happened before?
Has the weight of any great inventors invention ever just sent them I guess a
plane maybe.
Okay.
I mean,
that's some Frankincense Frankenstein Shit,
right?
I made you
really isn't good.
Segues night alive.
Does anybody ever written a segway?
Now that I'm shitting all over.
See a,
the battery powered Segue,
which is stabilized by,
by gyro scopes,
was invented by Dean Kamen,
who founded the company in 1999 wait a minute.
Oh,
it's just a segue owner.
I thought this was the guy who fucking invented at my fault.
Oh,
he's just a wealthy businessman.
Jesus Christ.
Isn't that classic?
Make the fucking have half the goddamn information.
Oh,
so it's not the guy who invented the fucking thing.
It's just some rich bastard who had one.
He didn't want to walk anymore.
Usually,
actually it looks like a hot shit,
you know,
like you drank some scotch and could tell the story.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Now I'm starting to feel bad.
Who the fuck is Dean Cayman
founder of the company in 1999 the unique transporter relies on electricity to
recharge his batteries and travels of speeds up to 12 and a half miles an hour.
I guess it's far more protective of the environment than other scooters and
automobiles.
The company says,
well Jesus Christ,
there's a big fucking red flag according to us,
our products,
the best claiming it's 11 times more efficient than the average American car.
Yeah.
And fucking 30 times slower.
You know what?
Fuck Dean Cayman.
All right.
If you learn anything from this week's podcast fucked Dean Cayman.
So anyways,
I just got back from Nashville,
Tennessee and Nashville fucking Tennessee and um,
I had a great God damn time out there.
I saw way more people out at my shows than the last time.
Um,
so let it go has been a great thing for me.
So I want to thank everybody who came out cause a,
I have a tough time when I go down south for all you guys who ever,
you know,
send me emails going,
come to Mississippi to north cack a lackey.
Come on bill.
You know you like college football,
come on to South Carolina,
check out damn game cocks.
Do a fuck and show problem is,
is I don't fucking talk like this so none of the other fuckers show up.
You guys don't fucking show up cause I'm not standing on stage with a camouflage
buttoned down shirt,
you know,
and a pair of murders or whatever the fuck you call them,
rubber boots you wear when you go out stomping around
in the fucking mud.
I'm actually jealous of your ability to hunt.
Got a God damn animal.
Fix it.
No where to shoot it.
Right.
I would do the south if you mother fuckers would show up.
I have a great idea for a tour.
All right.
Playing different venues and involves me going to some of my favorite teams and
the SEC.
Yeah.
For those of you who a only kind of like NFL football feel like you could become
a bigger football fan.
I'm telling you don't sleep on college football.
Um,
it's absolute insanity.
Like at this point,
just about every stadium holds at least 80 to 100,000 people and it's fucking
packed.
Every goddamn one I have go,
I would go see any team in the SCC except for that Mississippi one where it's
80,000 people with cowbells.
I have no desire to go into that fucking environment.
I think I really,
I'm really not into the noisemakers that's why not work new year's eve anymore.
You know,
all the,
all the women coming out there and the,
with their drunk boyfriends and they got that great Gatsby JP Morgan fucking hat
on,
except it's plastic.
Oh,
why would you want to,
I mean,
is there anything more annoying than those little horns that people blow on new
years?
[inaudible]
do you remember Jim Carrey,
dumb and dumber and he goes,
you want to hear the most annoying voice ever?
And that's what he sounded like.
And that's what it was.
So fucking funny to me because when he did that,
aside from the hilarious look on his face,
it immediately reminded me of standing on stage.
Um,
after I've done my set and I'm counting down,
Bill might doing the countdown.
You might do an Umi,
you mind starting your New Year that way,
standing on stage,
go and dad.
Nah,
you know what I would,
I would mind doing that.
I resent this entire fucking thing.
And the worst was whenever you do the,
uh,
um,
when you play a shitty club that doesn't know what the fuck they're doing,
the classic move that they make is they hand out the noisemakers before the
show.
Um,
which,
you know,
I don't even need to get into the details of why that's so fucking horrific.
But I remember a long time ago I was working Nick's comedy stop in Boston and uh
,
Wbz the local fucking station there wanted to shoot something for New Year's
Eve.
And we were shooting it in November.
So they handed out all the noise makers before any of us went up on stage.
And I remember there was this comedian Chris's Edo,
and I had no idea,
you know,
I was so new,
I had no idea that that was going to be a problem.
And I just remembered when I saw the look on this seasoned headliner,
Chrissy,
those face,
the look of panic on his face,
and he came walking into the club and the second he heard them,
this look I had never seen on his face because he's always,
you know,
relax dude.
And he's going,
what?
What do they have?
Noisemakers who handed out the noise makers?
He went right up to the person who ran the shit and Kudos to him,
got them to walk around the entire room and collect all the fucking noise makers
before we did the show,
which now I realize the brilliance of that move because we were going to go on
television and we would have bombed with what's in the background during our
entire fucking sets.
That was a long way to go.
But anyways,
so what I'm saying is,
uh,
I appreciate everybody coming down.
Hang on one second.
Did I just fucking blow this whole thing?
All right.
So evidently I didn't fuck it up.
I thought I'm,
I'm glad I didn't,
but I just saw this,
this plug was sticking way out.
Now how to fucking,
it'd be sticking out that far and it doesn't matter.
What is the purpose of having it in there.
See that,
look at me blaming technology rather than myself.
Um,
anyway,
so that wasn't new years story
shut up.
I'm going to pick up the ball and run with it.
So what I was talking about his,
his uh,
college football.
If you want to get into college football,
I'm telling you,
watch the SCC for my money.
That's where it's at.
I fucking,
uh,
I love like every Goddamn team in there except for like Vanderbilt,
like teams that just suck every year.
But uh,
and I was tempted when I was in Nashville to drive the two and a half hours or
whatever,
just to go see the first,
like I dunno,
halfway through the third quarter of the Tennessee game,
cause I've always wanted to go to a game out there.
You know that Purina cat chow fucking looking end zone and 100,000 people going
absolutely insane.
Um,
but,
um,
I dunno,
I just,
my show is at seven and I was going to have to leave and I would have been
fucking hammered.
I know I would have drank and I would've been driving across the 44 to fucking
west going back to fucking Nashville.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
let's talk a little NFL football,
shall we?
Um,
another awesome week of football and a,
this week I actually gambled a little bit.
I got a little running thing going with the,
another buddy of mine,
other comic buddy of mine were around were basically,
we're picking three games each week and you've got to bet against the spread.
And I went,
uh,
what did I go?
I think I went,
whoa.
I went one and two,
but if I teased them,
I would've won.
I think I would have,
this is what I had,
uh,
the team I won,
I had the bills getting 14 and a half,
which I almost fucking lost.
But,
uh,
I just,
I hate the Patriots.
Defense is fucking horrific.
You know,
we let up a ton of yards against the Bengals.
We let up.
Like,
I can't remember that Jill was a jets game.
Was it 30?
Was it over 30 was it 38 I can't fucking remember.
We've got our asses kicked and fucking defense looked horrible in that game and
our deep,
we just let up 30 points to the bills.
So sad to say Patriot fans,
myself included.
I see us going,
like if this trend continues at best,
I think maybe we're a 917 and a,
I was joking with my buddy watching the patriots,
uh,
you know,
we looked like we look like a fucking like a 2001 corvette.
That's the only way to describe it.
You know what I mean?
Where it can still fucking go zero to 60 really fast,
but it has a little that get,
get,
get fucking sound.
You know,
still a corvette.
But you now it's been beat on a little bit.
I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it.
It's just like,
we seem to have a lot of the tools,
but like we have no fucking pass rush,
great against the rubber boat.
And,
uh,
I don't know that one play where,
I mean,
who to first of all,
who the fuck is the bill's quarterback?
That's what really scared me.
You know what I mean?
Some people just have a look in their face,
they look like a quarterback and then other people look like they work at home
depot and whatever the fuck that guy's name was.
Fitzgerald and I noticed guides guys,
Goddamn name.
I was watching it at a sports bar.
What's the first half in a,
in Nashville.
And they had the sound down because everyone was watching obviously the titans
game cause I was in Tennessee.
And um,
I just kept looking at that guy's face in his red fucking beard.
And I was just like,
is that Eric Hippel?
Who,
who the fuck is that?
And he was just,
he was just going right down the goddamn field against us.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
this is this weird part of the year where a few,
if you gamble because you're trying to figure out,
you know,
what your team is,
which is really,
if you had any brains,
you wouldn't gamble for like the first six weeks of a season until you've got
some sort of consistency.
Right.
Because as much as I talk shit about the jets,
it's like they kicked the shit out of the Patriots.
He started taking,
well wait a minute,
maybe all this talk is for real.
But then it's like you kick the shit out of the team that,
that gave up 30 points to the bills,
you know,
and then you go down to the dolphins,
you play the dolphins and the dolphins have no fucking offense to speak of.
And it,
you basically couldn't put them away until the final fucking 20 seconds.
If that guy,
he had a fucking goddamn arm that would have been,
you know,
well no you can't say that cause I needed a two point conversion.
But,
um,
I dunno.
So,
okay,
let me finish with the bets I had then I had the fucking Lyons.
I'm getting 13 and a half.
I lost that one.
And then I had the saints given three and a half.
I went against my,
uh,
my theory about divisional rivalries and uh,
I was going to bet the dolphins,
but I just didn't like them given three to the jets just cause the jets have a
great,
uh,
a great defense.
And I didn't like the fact that the dolphins had no offense.
So I stayed away from that one.
And if I had to,
you know what it was,
I think I was leaning towards taking the jets with the points and I just
couldn't fucking get myself to,
then I'd be rooting for the jets and I just couldn't get myself to do it.
So having said all that,
the team that I think right now looks the best to me is the Pittsburgh Steelers.
They are three and o with the third stint,
third string quarterback.
And their defense looks fucking unbelievable.
And that they,
like they say that's what wins championships.
All right.
And I got a couple of emails.
Some jets fans go and you still going to keep hating on the jets.
You know,
typical jet fans are all excited because they're two and won three games into
the season.
Right?
And old fat boy wrote on that bus,
they're going to the Superbowl.
Um,
he says,
I know you hate the jets,
but are you going to let that cloud your objectivity and pick the jets to lose
for the next 13 weeks?
Now I'm not.
And yet that's actually a fair question because I hate New York teams to such a
level that it will cloud my objectivity.
But,
uh,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't get too excited there buddy.
Boy,
you guys have,
I mean,
the only team I think that you really played that had a serious like playoff
defense was the ravens and they held you to like nine points.
So you know,
I'm sure you're excited about beating the patriots,
but be honest with yourself.
True football fans.
The fact that the team that you kicked the shit out of just let up 30 points to
the Goddamn jet.
I'm bills.
I mean,
do you think jets,
do you guys think that you're going to do that?
I'm actually going to that game.
By the way,
the bills,
jets game,
I am going to that game because I'm doing a theater in Buffalo,
the Saturday,
uh,
night,
right before the game and I'm going to hang out.
I'm going to go there and with all my heart I'm going to root against the jets
even though I know the bills are going to fucking lose.
Um,
yeah.
So anyways,
is that all boring to people who aren't in the fucking sports?
So I,
I still,
I would say at this point,
I would say the two top contenders,
I would say the Steelers too early to say the chiefs,
whether they're for real or not and just cause the colts seem to win 13 games
every year,
but they always blow it in the fucking playoffs.
But the best thing that jets have going for them,
I seriously think is the fact that Sanchez hasn't thrown an interception yet.
And yes,
I hope that jinx is him into throwing five next week.
But if he's going to play like that,
you know,
uh,
I don't know.
I just don't,
you're not a fucking Superbowl team.
Fuck the jets.
All right,
let's get to some youtube videos.
No,
you know what,
I gotta,
I gotta tell you something that's been fucking bugging the shit out of me.
Yeah.
They have a friend.
You just fucking outgrow them.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I don't even want to get into this shit.
You just fucking,
you did just,
it's like,
you know,
you're chugging along,
you're doing your shit,
you'll life's go and good and their life isn't going good.
And then eventually what that ends up happening is all of a sudden they just
start making little snide remarks about your life.
You now,
and then he got to sit there and go,
wow,
that was fucking weird than I do.
And I'm just fucking around.
I'm sorry man,
I'm fucking,
they always end up apologizing.
Nah,
I'm just going through some shit,
blah,
blah.
And then it just becomes more and more and more.
I,
you know,
I got this fucking buddy of mine and it's just like,
he's one of these fucking guys,
his life is all fucked up.
Just think of every dumb thing that you could do,
every dumb thing that you could do to fuck up your life,
you know?
Okay.
Smoking weed,
gambling,
uh,
you know,
being high at work,
flunking drug tests,
losing jobs,
getting drunk,
falling down,
fucking up your face,
that type of shit,
that type of Shit,
right?
One of those fucking guys calls you up with a crisis every six fucking weeks,
dude,
you'd have to believe it would ever been.
It's never their fault.
One of those fucking guys where it's just like,
all right,
you know,
you choose to live your life that way.
That's how you live your life.
But then they fucking come on,
they make snide remarks at you,
and then you want to come back and just fucking unload on him.
You know,
it'd be like,
dude,
you're fucking a drug test working at a goddamn fruit stand.
You fucking loser.
You know,
why don't you come home and blow some more fucking weed smoke into your family's
face as you give them,
you know,
$3 for the fucking week.
You know,
that's what you want to say,
but you don't,
you wait to your podcast.
Yeah man.
It's just like,
ah,
that's one of those,
that's one of those things you guys [inaudible] you guys have any stories like
that?
Cause I really don't want to talk anymore about this,
but I know you do.
Come on.
Some of you guys out there,
you're doing well,
right?
Maybe somebody you were friends with when you were both struggling with isn't
doing well yet.
All right.
But they're so busy focusing on,
on,
on what you're doing that are,
they don't need,
they start giving me this roundabout shit.
Oh my God,
that's fucking dude
saw my special right.
And leaves me this fucked up message.
Right?
And then just click hangs up and I'll call him back for like,
you know,
10 days or whatever week or So.
Call the dude up.
I'm like,
listen to what the fuck was with that message.
You know,
it's like,
if you're not happy with you own life,
fix your life.
The fuck you taken it out on me for,
you know,
and then he,
and he texted me back some bullshit about a dude.
I was just joking.
Don't be so insecure,
you know?
And it's just a really is,
is that what the fuck?
And then I go to column and his phone is off
fucking idiot.
Um,
insecurity of the guys.
Got To fucking smoke weed all the Goddamn time.
Turn your life into a movie because you can't fucking deal
looking at the God damn ceiling.
Hey,
you fucking moron.
Anyway,
let's plow ahead here.
Plowing ahead.
If you've got any fucking stories like that.
This is just getting negative.
Um,
let me,
Oh,
do I want to fucking unload on this guy?
I want to fucking unload on this guy.
I really do.
And I'm going to say,
I just know I'm going to say shit and then that's just going to be the end of
it.
And uh,
that's why I'm not,
that's why I'm just choosing my words,
words very carefully,
still saying things really conti.
Um,
but I'm not worried about him here in this cause he's too fucking high till even
he doesn't even have to use a computer,
you know.
So I,
I basically could go off on whatever.
Send me your stories.
So Cathartic Lee,
I can fucking,
I in a Cathartic way,
if I'm using that word correctly,
I can go off on your friends rather than my own.
All right,
let's get into some advice.
The asset bill section of the week.
Uh,
Bill,
I'd appreciate it.
Uh,
if you could give my friend some advice concerning a girl.
My friend is in college and works part time at a restaurant as a waiter.
Within the past few weeks they hired a girl to host and bus tables on some of
the days he works.
I think you going to say literally this girl was hosting and busing tables.
I was just like,
ah,
that's kind of nasty.
Uh,
I told you guys that story right when I was working for that restaurant that was
going out of business and at one point I was the grill chefs.
I don't know,
I told this story,
but I actually worked on a mesquite grill with one of those top chef hats on,
glassed in.
Like I knew what the fuck I was doing and I also bus tables and wash the dishes,
you know,
in this like I'd cook the meal and as I was cooking it,
I would be watching other people trying to see if they were done eating and when
they were,
I would ducked down behind the grill,
take off the hat and my apron and underneath it I had that half a Tuxedo that
you were in a restaurant that tries to look like it's fancy.
And I would come out there,
my face red from working on the grill
from it being so God damn hot in there.
I'd bust the table and then I would go back,
throw out the food,
scrape off the plates and load up the load and it fucking put it in the
dishwasher,
not wash my hands because I didn't have time because I had to run back to make
sure the medium rare burger didn't become medium.
That's what I thought you were suggesting there.
Um,
so keep an eye on the employees.
People,
make sure there's no double agents at the fucking restaurants you go to or you
do not want to eat their little tip.
All right.
Here we go.
Plowing ahead.
Uh,
well the hell were we,
uh,
they developed,
they quickly developed a relationship where he would hang out in her dorm
between classes for hours at a time doing what college kids do.
I guess he really thought that she was the one.
Uh,
I tried to tell him to slow down a bit because nothing good comes from obsessing
in that early pre relationship period.
Anyways,
a week into it,
she tells him that she's really not looking for a relationship because she
doesn't want to get tied in with the guy and get distracted from school.
They pretty much agreed to be friends with benefits in parentheses.
He says,
I hate that term.
Yeah,
they're going to be fuck buddies.
Um,
sounds reasonable to me.
Then I guess he overheard something during work or you had called her and this
other guy answered or something.
Answer the phone.
Anyway,
he finds out that she's already going out with some other dude,
like a full on relationship.
So now my friend has to work with this client and try to go on like nothing
happened,
happened.
You know what's great,
why my voice always cracks was cause I fucking screamed my act the night before
actually the two nights before.
So he has to go around and act like nothing happened.
Uh,
what should he say to her?
I feel bad for him since he would talk on and on about her,
about this girl everyday.
I appreciate the insight bill.
If you read this.
Um,
all right.
What should he say to her?
Nothing.
He shouldn't say anything.
Uh,
she's a young girl who doesn't know how to get out of a relationship yet,
or maybe she's afraid to be alone.
I don't know what,
but uh,
what he should do is,
uh,
he should stop attempting to fucker his best move was just to be cool.
It's going to be hard because he likes her.
Just be like,
Hey,
what's going on?
And uh,
and kind of leave it at that.
And if she comes up like,
well,
how come you're not talking to me?
No,
there's something weird what's going on guys?
And just be like,
look,
I'm not trying to be a jerk,
but I kind of got wind that year that you have a boyfriend.
And uh,
so,
you know,
I don't mess with girls who have boyfriends.
That's all.
I'm not judging you or anything,
but uh,
yeah.
So,
you know,
I actually Kinda liked you and uh,
when I found out you had it,
I guess that's the first thing you should do.
There you go.
Putting the cart before the horse
he should find out.
But I really wouldn't find out from her.
Find out from someone who kind of knows and just be like,
she has a boyfriend.
Right.
And then,
and then when you've clarified that she has a boyfriend,
then just keep the conversation short a how you doing?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And eventually when you don't try to find your friend doesn't try to fuck her
again or hookup or whatever,
she's going to be like a,
you know,
what's going on.
This things seem like it's going on with you.
Hey you hey.
You know I ain't do that shit.
I'm trying to fill yours.
It's a matter they did everything.
All right.
Between like things are
still cool cause I just kinda noticed you just Kinda let me,
he said hello to me but used to stop and you know,
maybe can compliment they are looking at or anything.
Perfect.
Oh the end of that bullshit.
Right.
And just be like,
uh,
yeah.
You know,
I just kind of heard through the grapevine that you have a boyfriend,
a serious full on relationship boyfriends.
So uh,
kind of threw me for a loop because you never brought it up.
Oh yeah.
That um,
Kay.
Ah,
all right.
I should have said something and right there,
you know,
she just trying to warm her way out of it with the long pauses between what
she's saying.
Yeah.
That bullshit and just,
I just don't say anything and just look at her as she stammers her way through
it.
If she does,
she might be one of these people who like,
she's probably going to just turn around and fucking walk away because a,
she doesn't like confrontations.
She could deal with confrontation.
She'd get out of that fucking relationship and be like,
look,
I'm not happy.
Okay.
I,
yeah,
so get your books in your Letterman jacket and fucking beat it,
you know,
whatever the hell you got to say.
Um,
yeah,
so I,
did I give any advice or did I just imitate this girl that I never met?
That's what I would do.
I would confirm from someone who knows her really well,
that she has a boyfriend and when she,
and just be nice to her,
hey,
what's going on?
You don't want to create any fucking shit at work because you need the job.
You don't want to lose your,
your,
uh,
any money or whatever.
Look,
at the end of the day,
you fucking banged her.
All right?
So that's a plus.
Uh,
you know,
that's not the kind of girl you want to marry.
Someone would be in a full on fucking relationship and would,
would,
uh,
try to set up where you're,
you're,
you're fucking somebody else on the side.
That's not the mother,
your kids,
you know,
I mean,
grant y'all think saving her.
She's young,
so she has some growing up to do.
But uh,
yeah,
you don't wanna be involved in that because the next thing you know,
you're the guy in the fall on relationship with her and she's banging some other
way to run the side when she doesn't have to break up with you.
So I would stay away from that girl and uh,
that's it.
Then I would also stop fucking people where I work.
That's another thing.
You don't shit where you eat,
where you eat.
It's something you do when you're young.
You know,
you just,
you just fucking your vicinity and you fulfill it.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I would try to avoid doing that.
So that's basically my advice.
Do you want me to say it again?
I just keep saying the same thing over and over again in different order.
That's a,
that's how I would handle that situation.
And,
uh,
and with that,
I think I'm pretty much out of information that people have given to me this
week.
Let me do the math here.
Had done 36 minutes.
I owe you another 14.
The fuck am I going to talk about?
If I could get on the Goddamn Internet,
I try to fucking pick some teams next week.
Who Do you guys like tonight?
Greenbay and the bears.
This is one of these classic early season match ups where you're going to get to
see who's for real.
You know which bears team is going to show up.
The one that technically lost to the lions in the first fucking week or the one
that manhandled the cowboys last week.
I don't know.
I like Mike Martz is a fucking offensive coordinator.
Um,
if I was a gambling man,
cause I just do bullshit,
you know,
we're basically,
it's like a hundred bucks for the year.
Whoever has the best fucking record.
I know that's a pussy bed.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
but if I had to gamble tonight,
this might be,
I,
if I would take the home team,
I would take the fucking home team on this one.
Well,
how the fuck can you say that bill,
without seeing the Goddamn points spread?
That's a great point.
That is a great fucking point.
Come on,
get me online.
Pale his fucking money for this shit.
Whatever you guys want me to some youtube videos for the week.
I got some great ones.
I have some great ones.
Here we go,
uh,
African American man hoses off a white woman who called him.
And it's basically the n word.
All right?
You have to watch this video.
It's fucking phenomenal.
And,
uh,
like I always say,
if you want to,
uh,
rather than search all of these yourself,
just go to the [inaudible],
podcast.com t h e m m podcast.com,
the Mlm,
podcast.com,
the official a fan page for the Monday morning podcasts.
We'll have all the youtube videos right in the fucking row.
Um,
and you can just,
you can just blow right through them.
All right.
So look up African American man hoses off a white woman who called them,
uh,
the n word and it's just awesome.
She's in one of those motorized,
you know,
those motorized carts that people who can walk but you know,
don't feel like it drive,
I don't understand them.
It's different than a wheelchair.
Wheelchair for the most part means you can't walk.
But those motorized carts mean,
uh,
I dunno,
I think you can't walk for long.
Yeah.
You can't walk for long distances and a,
so they are sort of drive and you have an inability to stand up on a segway and
you're worried that you're going to drive off a cliff and go into a fucking
river.
So anyways,
guys,
Washington is fucking 85 caprice classic I believe.
And this woman just fuck it is on the other side of the street yelling at him
and he just starts fucking,
you know what I love?
It's not that he just sort of like,
you know,
back and forth hoses it rough.
Like he's spraying a garden,
he full on blast or in the face and just holds it there.
And it's really great because it's the whole,
like when black people used to,
you know,
we had to march for civil rights in the fucking evil white people would be
holding the hose in their face.
It's come full circle now.
Here we are 40 fucking years later,
50 years almost.
And now the black dude is holding it in,
then the white person's face.
Uh,
but it's just a garden hose.
So it's hilarious.
He's just spraying or just not moving.
It goes.
Say it again,
say it again,
bitch.
It's fucking awesome.
Ah,
and when she drives away in the end and is still giving them shit and she's
soaking wet,
I mean it was just one of the fucking great laughs I've had in a,
let's just one of the,
I just,
it was awesome.
I just fucking die laughing watching it and I'm,
all right.
Here's the next one.
This one is actually really,
I can't believe this guy didn't get hurt really bad,
uh,
airbag test in Russia.
MMM.
This guy has to go at least nine feet in the fucking air and lands like a
Goddamn rag doll.
And his friends are just laughing at him.
I mean,
just the concussive force alone,
what that would do to your ear drums is a,
is beyond me.
It,
speaking of that,
a reoccurring theme on this podcast,
I've brought it up a few times because I've done permanent damage to my ears
from seeing bands live music and playing drums.
Um,
I'm telling you because I was out in Nashville,
my buddy out there took me out to some clubs that I always have the earplugs.
And I was actually talking to this guy who was about my age and,
uh,
from what his friends were saying,
you know,
got a lot of ass back in the day.
All right.
And he was,
see,
saw that it had on earplugs.
He goes,
what?
do you wear those all the time?
I go,
yeah,
I try to.
He goes,
yeah,
because recently I went to the doctor and the guy said,
hey,
will you ever in the military?
And he said No.
And he asked,
did you work in,
in,
in a machine shop?
Basically asking all those fucking questions.
And the guy just said no.
And I'm telling you,
it was from years of going out to bars where they got the music cranked way too
fucking loud and uh,
you know that shit we hitting on the girl.
Yeah.
Do you live around here?
You literally leaning into her ear,
you're screaming into her fucking ear.
Like just imagine if there was no music on and somebody did that to you,
you'd punch him in the face.
But when you're in those clubs,
the music is so fucking loud that someone has to get right near your ear and
yell into it just so you can hear him.
So I'm telling you.
MMM.
How do you know how the fuck I got on this subject?
Oh,
I guess see the airbag tests,
you know,
I know you're young and then you've got ear plugs.
What do you will fucking queer up telling you?
Put those goddamn things in.
If you ever want to experiment one night,
just where one where one and standing there for a fucking half hour and walk out
and take the other one out and feel the difference.
Your,
you're the ear that didn't have one is going to feel like it's underwater.
And every time you do that you're doing permanent.
Like you ever have your ears ring out of nowhere.
You just walking down the street and they go,
Oh yeah,
that means you have,
you have permanent hearing damage.
Uh,
so where are your ear plugs?
Their kids?
Is this crisis,
one of the fucking corneas things I've ever said,
but I dunno,
it's driven people to suicide.
So cause it just keeps getting louder.
All right,
here's another,
here's another fucking youtube video.
This one is unbelievable.
It's called Uks best free runners and uh,
it's like a six minute video.
Usually.
I don't like videos this long,
but this is,
these are these people who basically,
um,
run and jump off of like,
you know,
out of second story windows land and roll and keep going and do like a fucking
back flip and then run up the side of a tree and then do another back flip.
The fucking unbelievable.
And the only thing that this video is missing is I want to see a free runner get
chased by a cop on foot because this dude,
one of these guys,
he fucking runs at uh,
you know those,
those big,
um,
when you go down there like a,
uh,
like a,
a wharf,
if you're not doing a drug deal or whatever,
you know those big containers that they basically lift off of the ship and they
can put on the back of a an 18 wheeler.
That's what the basic,
it looks like.
It looks like that the back of an 18 wheeler,
this fucking dude is running full speed at it and then runs two steps like Bo
Jackson up the side of the thing and then grabs the top of it and does a pull up
and pulls himself up.
And this is all one motion continues to run and then jumps like a six feet,
six foot gap over to this other building where he's got where he's got to reach
up,
jump to the ledge,
does another pull up and now he's up on the building.
All of that takes about a second and a half.
And I would just,
would have loved to seen a cop chase in this dude and he just want,
you know,
even if he wanted to shoot him,
he couldn't have got the gun out quick enough and it would just,
would have been like,
yeah,
pursuits over.
I don't know.
I,
he was in front of me and then he ran up a fucking building.
Now Dude,
I'm telling you,
he ran up a building.
I didn't have time to shoot him.
Well,
you fucking chase.
Uh,
um,
check that out is another quick one.
Ladies teeth fall out during divorce court.
That's pretty much self explanatory.
Um,
then I've got a couple of Tourette's videos.
There's a guy with Tourette's,
Tourette's,
Karaoke,
um,
tourettes karaoke and the guys doing rdms losing my religion.
It's fucking hilarious.
Then there's a,
there's another one out there called,
uh,
the best of Tourette's guy.
And,
uh,
I,
I'm,
I'm convinced the guy's an actor because he doesn't have Tourette's as far as,
you know,
being on the opie and Anthony Show and being around people with Tourette's for a
long fucking time.
It's sort of a rep repetition of either weird noises and there is cursing.
But the way this guy's cursing,
it's Torres.
It's not Tourette's,
Tourette's.
It's not tourettes,
but it's fucking hilarious.
So look up Tourette's guy.
Um,
and that's it.
That's what I got this week.
I'm sorry.
I have the windows open.
We've got a heat wave out here.
If you can hear that fucking lawn mower
of a,
the dude down the street.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
I'm gonna die in this fucking podcast.
What do we got here?
30 minutes and 16.
That's 46.
All right,
I need another four minutes.
I apologize.
This has been a fucking lame one this week.
Um,
what do I got to let me hate my gigs that I have coming up?
Oh wait,
I'm back online.
No,
but now it's back off.
Jesus Christ.
What kind of life am I living?
Kind of life.
Am I living here?
I can't even get on my own.
God Damn podcast.
Oh wait,
wait,
wait.
I'm using the schedule here using my schedule.
All right.
This is what I have coming up this weekend.
I am going to be in Albany,
New York at the egg and the egg.
You sons of bitches.
All you people live in upstate New York who like come to Syracuse,
come to Albany,
do the Lake Ontario play house stowed.
Um,
and I always play New York City.
I am doing two out of the way gigs in upstate New York.
I'm doing the egg Albany,
which a lot of people don't realize is the capital of New York,
Albany.
And then the next night I am at the uh,
the Buffalo.
What the fuck is this?
Let me see what we got here.
Buffalo Center for the Arts University at Buffalo Center for the arts.
Um,
both shows are at 8:00 PM.
Please come out,
please come out.
And uh,
just to show you what kind of a sports fan I am,
I'm hanging out the next day.
I'm going to the bills jets game and I don't fly out to the next day and the
buffalo Sabres are playing the flyers.
So I'm going to that game too.
Why the fuck wouldn't you,
why wouldn't you?
And um,
I also have some cool radio coming up.
I'm doing Adam Carolla's podcast on Wednesday.
Um,
October 29th.
Adam Carolla as far as I know,
has the biggest podcast on the Internet.
Um,
the guy's killing it,
so I'm going to be on that on Wednesday,
September 29th,
I'm sorry,
September 29th and later on that day I'm also going to be doing,
uh,
Jamie Foxx is show on Sirius satellite radio,
the foxhole.
And I believe Jamie's not going to be there,
but earthquake and uh,
who do I forget who else is going to be there?
Um,
check that one out and I'm going to be on a doctor drew show love line on
October 6th.
Huh?
Look at me moving up in the radio world.
Those are three famous fucking people's shows I'm doing.
Um,
later on this month,
I'm coming out to Minnesota in Chicago to do one night or is it theaters?
And these tickets are selling tremendously.
So if you think going to go and get the tickets now because,
uh,
I am blown away by the response out there and play in the pantageous theater in
Minneapolis,
Minnesota on October 22nd,
I'm playing the Vic Theater in Chicago,
Illinois the following weekend.
And uh,
and here's a quick date that I opened up doing one night only at the funny bone
in Saint Louis on October 30th,
October 30th,
everybody one night only.
So come on down,
check out my new hour.
All my material is 100% different from,
uh,
from the let it go special.
And speaking of that,
let it go.
We'll be aired again on comedy central October 1st.
Please watch it.
Um,
if you can watch it live because that,
those are the only ones that I get credit for as far as the ratings.
Um,
you guys want to hear a little behind the behind the curtain show business shit.
This is how it works.
How the ratings work is they don't count Tivo watches if you record it and then
you watch and they don't count it because you know,
when I know that you blow through the commercials and ratings exists so they can
figure out how much that they can charge advertisers so they can figure out how
many people are actually watching the goddamn commercials.
So,
um,
October 1st comedy central is showing,
uh,
let it go again.
And uh,
that's pretty much it.
Oh.
And a Halloween,
I'm hanging out and I'm going to the rams game in St Louis,
so there you go.
That is it.
And just so if you want to plan ahead,
I got the funny bone in Columbus,
Ohio,
November 12th,
13th and 14th and then a,
I'm in DC at the listener auditorium on,
uh,
November 19th.
And then I'm doing Foxwoods,
right?
Foxwoods day.
You Go Foxwoods on November 20th.
There's another one,
people don't come to Connecticut.
I'm in Connecticut,
November 20th and a and then the last one I will give you as I'm at the Moore
Theater in Seattle,
November 27th.
And,
uh,
the,
this is a cute little mini run for me.
This is the first time I actually tried to do theaters on my own,
so I'm really excited about all that.
All this and this.
How much of a sports fan I am.
I'm flying in the Friday night,
uh,
to do the radio so you know,
to the radio to hype it.
Th The uh,
the Damn Gig and I'm actually going to drive down and go to that Trailblazer
Hornets game and then I'm going to the CDC,
I'll Seahawks game on the Sunday afterwards and I brought all of that up as the
lovely Nia just walked in here.
The lovely Nia just walked in here.
Does that make you upset?
And I spending an extra day on the road to go to a football game.
Huh?
Come here.
Come in here.
It's not until the end of next month.
I like football.
I love you.
But I like football.
Come here,
come over here.
Oh,
she just slammed down her purse as if to say,
you know,
you don't like the rams.
Saint Louis Rams makes her about the rams there.
One of the original teams that made up the NFL and uh,
they were in Los Angeles for a while and that didn't work out well.
Worked out for a while and then they,
then,
then they,
then they moved down.
I don't care to Anaheim.
We're Disney land is one of the happy places.
And then after while punch you in your patronizing red face.
Come on,
if I fight,
this is a technique that,
you know what?
I have OCD.
All right?
If I go to that rams game,
the only team in,
in,
in the Midwest,
first of all,
you don't have OCD.
Stop being dramatic.
There are people who actually have OCD and they want to kill themselves.
You don't have OCD.
You like going to football games.
That doesn't mean you have those cds.
See that that's what you need in your life.
You need a woman who can put you in your place when you're being ridiculous.
Was I being ridiculous?
Yes.
You just gave me the look.
Really
stop cursing on the podcast.
You know,
I had enough of you.
See that these supposed to be honest in a fucking relationship.
I told you what I'm doing rather than coming home,
I'm going to the fucking rams game.
Oh,
here she comes.
To be honest with you,
the fact that you've been on the road constantly and are choosing to stay out
longer is really fucking rude.
I have two weeks off.
Yeah,
exactly where you should be home.
I'm going to be home during those two weeks.
These are,
these fucking games are in like November except for the fine go.
I don't want to see you anyway,
except for the two in October.
Uh,
she just gave me the finger.
Your pumpkin bread or I'm going to do the Pumpkin's and I'm also going to make
the pumpkin bread.
I'm big on Halloween.
Everybody.
I like it.
You don't have to,
but you have to buy any gifts.
You know all these kids coming up the stairs.
Dress like Godzilla though.
Yeah,
it's adorable and I make it.
How great was the Pumpkin bread I made last year?
It was great.
You make great pumpkin bread.
You're a great baker.
That was all insulting.
It was great.
It was great pumpkin bread.
You're a great,
but you know what,
you know I don't,
you know what,
I,
I'm smart enough not to engage in this with you.
This,
Ooh,
this is just your way of saying that you love me and you miss me,
so I'm not gonna engage in this.
I love you too.
Ah,
see,
figured that one out.
Go,
go,
go.
Pour yourself a bowl of cereal.
Get out of my face.
I'm going to finish this up.
Oh,
fucking cheap shot.
There's a woman ever just square up and just go,
let's go.
They don't,
they wait till you're not looking in your fucking throw a punch.
Fucking cheap.
I was nice.
It was right where my appendix used to be.
Did you have your appendix out?
Um,
yes I did.
I had it out back in the day,
way back in the day on those little house in the prairie days where you almost
died of it because people didn't know what's wrong with you walking around.
You face the same color as glue.
Your Dad just going,
what's wrong with that guy?
Your bed,
you're being a baby.
I feel like there's somebody invisible stabbing me in my side.
Ah,
c'mon.
C'Mon.
Stop it.
Grow Up.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
so please,
um,
check out,
check out my special October 1st if you missed it and please buy tickets to my
shows.
I have a brand new hour.
I have a big theater tour coming up.
And uh,
you know what else I didn't mention?
I didn't mention this shit.
All right,
because this is how I booked myself in the road.
I have to whisper here so nia doesn't figure this shit out at how I book myself
on the road is take like the funny bone in Columbus,
Ohio.
All right,
I'm going to be there the 12th,
13th and 14th of November.
Why did we pick this weekend?
You know what I mean?
Who the fuck?
Why the fuck would you ever go to Columbus,
Ohio?
There's only one fucking reason and that's to go to Ohio state buckeyes game.
Other than that,
there's no fucking reason unless you want to join a militia or maybe use that as
your base camp as you drive down to go see that chick who plays with the
pretenders and I forget where the fuck she's from.
So anyways,
Ohio state is playing Penn state that day.
And uh,
I'm really rolling the dice because of the flex schedule,
which is basically if Ohio state and Penn state are ranked really high,
that game will then become an eight o'clock game.
So not only will I not get to go to the game,
nobody will show up to my fucking show because everyone's going to be at the
fucking Goddamn Ohio state game.
All right.
And I'm telling you people,
if you,
if you come from like a town I come from,
which is a professional sports team,
a professional sports town,
you have no fucking idea how insane it can get.
Like as much as they talk about the Yankees,
red sox rivalry and how fucking insane it can't hold a candle to Ohio state,
Michigan.
If you don't believe me.
Hbo Did a documentary on it and it's,
it's absolutely fucking insane.
And I'll tell you right now,
if Fenway Park or Yankee Stadium Somehow held a 100,000 fucking people,
they wouldn't sell it out.
You couldn't get 100,000 people to go to that.
I don't think you'd get 100,000 people to go to a fucking world series game.
Um,
but college football,
they'll fucking have 100,000 people just to watch.
Ohio state kicked the shit out of bowling green.
They don't give a shit.
They just show up.
Um,
anyways,
that is the podcast for this week.
And I realized is
that a,
I didn't address that my podcast has been taken off of iTunes.
Uh,
I believe that was something that I did.
Can't figure out what it is,
but,
um,
I have some people working on it and I didn't even address it because I'm hoping
it's just gonna be a one week problem and a,
that is it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Good luck to everybody.
I know who the fucking patriots have next week we have the dolphins.
And I'll tell you right now,
I don't like that game.
I don't fucking like it until we have a goddamn defense.
I don't like any game that we're playing.
I don't like it,
but I'm loving Hernandez.
I'm loving that guy.
But I'm hoping Mohs is going to get some more touches because he's going to
start bitching or something.
I don't fucking know.
God Damn it.
That's my prediction right now.
The way we've played the first three weeks and all the points we let up,
I'm saying we're going to go nine and seven.
Um,
and we might even be tied for second with the dolphins and they might even be 10
and six jets might go 11 and five.
Um,
I got to wait to the jets actually play another contender.
I know we're playing the Steelers.
I don't know if the jets play them,
but that's going to be a big game when Ben Roethlisberger is back.
I'll tell you what Chet fans,
I'll tell you this right now.
Okay.
And know that the reason why I gave the jet so much shit A's because they're
from New York and also because they were talking so much fucking shit.
That's what happens.
And noticed after they got their fucking asses kicked,
they didn't get their asses kicked but they lost,
where's all the shit talking now they shut the fuck up,
which is actually me hating the jets.
I kind of wished that they beat the ravens cause they still would have been
talking and then they would have been in a situation like the 2007 Patriots were
the entire league wants to kick the shit out of you.
And eventually someone does and you go home sad with your head hanging down.
But I will tell you this,
if you guys do play the fucking Steelers,
alright in Big Ben is back and uh,
you know,
and you guys beat him,
then I will say you guys are for are for real.
All right,
and as much as you,
New Yorkers can't fucking stand,
stand me.
You've got to admit that's how you have to be.
You can't just say this shit and not be the shit and then everybody just says
you're the shit unless you're Peyton Manning,
of course,
who can just do no fucking wrong.
Right,
right.
Once again,
he's off to with these on a fucking tear,
putting up ridiculous numbers and I'll tell you this fucking cult fans,
if pate manning wins three super bowls with the regular season stats that he's
put up,
if you want to say that he's the best guy who ever played that position at that
point,
I would have a hard time arguing with because he would,
he would have that final piece that he needed,
which was leading your team in the playoffs to the promise land as opposed to
getting them to the promise land.
You're right there at the gates of Wally world and then throwing a pick six to
fucking John Candy and he runs it back 60 yards.
All right,
so for all you fucking guys,
cause you guys love your team so much.
You're not even listening to what I'm saying.
All said was rex Ryan is his out of his fucking mind.
He's not as confident as he acts.
He cries himself to sleep with a fucking gallon of ice cream every night.
And uh,
he has,
uh,
a as a,
a chronic need to be liked.
And I am right on all of those fucking points.
I don't give a shit.
And I also said that all this shit you were talking was bullshit,
which was proven in the first fucking week when you lost.
All right?
So when you,
when you beat a legitimate super bowl contender,
which you have yet to fucking play,
all you've played so far is one team that has a playoff level defense and you
didn't beat them all.
Right?
Really?
Do you think the dolphins are going to win the Superbowl?
Do you really think you're going to run into them again in the fucking playoffs
with their no name Qb?
You're not.
Do you think the Patriots are going to do anything letting up 30 points a
fucking game than not?
I know that because Belicheck is still there and Tom Brady is still there.
You think that they're still the o four or o seven paths?
They're not.
This is,
this is a whole new fucking team and um,
and it's fucking ridiculous.
We have to score like 35 38 points to get a victory.
We scored 38 points on the bills,
38 points and it was still a nail biter right down to the fucking end.
All right,
whatever.
It's fucking frustrating.
And you guys couldn't beat the dolphins to till the last God damn play the game.
And you guys are sitting there talking super bowl.
Is that what you ice cream fucking eating fags down there in New York?
Is that what you're doing?
Who's team actually plays in New Jersey?
All you douchebags ago.
Why did you call the New England patriots?
There's not even a Boston team.
That's how dumb New Yorkers are.
They don't realize that Massachusetts is in New England.
It's a region of the northeast.
All right?
For All you folks who don't know your history,
the Boston Patriots started out,
they played at Nickerson field.
Nobody showed up because nobody knew who the fuck they were.
It was considered an a farrier league.
They were going bankrupt and in a desperate attempt to try to rope in more
fucking fans,
they switched to New England patriots.
Something that I have never liked.
I still think that they should be called the Boston patriots.
All that fucking Patriot tea party horse,
shit all happened at Boston.
They should be called the Boston patriots,
but they're not.
So that's why,
but Boston is in New England.
You're dumb,
New York or Fox and you guys got a lot of nerve considering the New York jets
and the New York giants play in New Jersey and share a fucking stadium.
Just why don't you guys stay on the fuck down.
All right.
See,
that's what always happens.
Always make good points about football.
And then my hatred of New York just comes up.
But admit it.
You love it.
Every God damn you know something.
I actually don't even hate the giants.
I actually liked the giants.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I liked the uniforms.
I like the old helmet that they went back to.
I like them.
I like this style of play,
that smash Mouth Defensive Shit.
I know that they kind of suck so far,
but I,
um,
I coffins a good coach.
Maybe you can turn it around.
I don't know.
I don't
know what,
but uh,
there's something about the jets.
I just,
there,
you know what it is.
Their fans are desperate and there's just something,
when you smell desperation,
you just want to see failure.
You know,
they just slept in about that silly little fireman on top of his boyfriends
shoulders and they're 1920s cheer,
j e t as jets,
jets,
and they,
and they think that that chair is awesome.
That's what kills me the same way it kills me when red sox fan sink sweet
Caroline and they think it's awesome to be going [inaudible] with your fucking
chicks head on your shoulder.
I swear to God,
if I could,
if I became the next Hitler,
but going big on this one,
the people that I would target would be red sox fans.
Anybody who sings [inaudible] in the seventh inning of a red sox game and anyone
who puts a fireman on their shoulder and goes,
j e t as jets,
jets,
jets.
That's it.
You're out.
You're fucking out.
You're done.
All right.
You're not part of my master plan.
Ah,
Gee,
she is.
How fucked up was that?
Well,
go fuck yourself.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all the police come out to my shows.
I got a brand new hour and,
um,
I,
I think I have a new girl.
I think I have a new,
uh,
fun joke about a goat.
I'm hoping that killed in Nashville,
but God knows those Pete Guy knows the people down there.
Come on,
man.
Who's kidding?
Who,
how does a goat joke not killed in fucking Tennessee?
All right.
The real test.
It's not even going to be in Albany.
I think he'll be in buffalo.
Albany animal is a lot of farmland around there.
Do you know,
let's the highway.
I hate the most [inaudible] 87 north just because for so much of my career,
I drove up there in either a bus or a rental car,
just go into some fucking nightmare of a gig.
So I just always associated with that.
I have talked too long.
I have overstayed my welcome.
God bless all year.
I'll see you next week.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].